this guy started a business selling hot
dogs and he was given One Wish from a
genie of what competitive Advantage he
would be able to have the first thought
he had was like maybe I'll make my hot
dogs cheaper the genie shook his head
and was like no what if I made my hot
dogs taste better and the genie said no
don't waste your wish on that or the
guy's thinking maybe I'll just make mine
the fastest cooking so I can serve the
hot dogs faster the genie said that's
not what you want to waste your wish on
so the genie looked at him holding the
hot dogs and buns in hand and said it's
not about the hot dogs if you want to
build an amazing business you want to
put your hot dog stand on the best
corner in front of a starving crowd
because if your hot dog stand is on the
corner it doesn't matter how cheap they
are how good they taste how fast they
cook the moment that hungry crowd walks
out and sees your hot dog stand you're
going to sell it every time